this is how it started long queues
outside polling stations on the first of
a three-day vote
state workers mobilized to give united
russia the ruling party a pick-me-up
from the word go
in my work
say you must
tomorrow go
what
on day what and
i hear
do you feel that your work knows who you
vote for are you still free to vote for
who you want to i
will use
smart water
and i know
my choice
smart voting the tactical voting
strategy pushed by team navalny labelled
extremist in russia may have shifted
things
the ruling party retaining its majority
no seismic shifts in the political
status quo even if it does look as
though the communists have done quite
well one twist in what has been a very
straight jacketed election
president putin cast his vote online
from quarantine
active
but three days of voting needs three
times as many observers to watch out for
moments like this
the hooded figure at the front busily
stuffing votes into the ballot box or
here watch the hand by the flag pretty
standard stuff for russian elections
because of
plus independent election monitors warn
that online voting straight into a state
portal is impossible to monitor
you can't control it absolutely it is
absolutely transparent we don't know the
code
we nobody have seen it
except of uh the owners of this code so
we don't know does it really count or ju
or maybe just drawn the results
[Music]
alexander artiomov is working for a
local electoral committee in moscow
bringing the ballot to people too frail
to leave home
and do you think these elections are
free or fair
uh
as in
uh
i'm not allowed to say this
but but these actions are not free nor
fair
he's doing his bit to make sure the vote
gets to those who want it
to at least give the feel of
participation and the semblance of
democracy
something the russian state has proven
pretty emphatically over the past year
that it is not
dinah magnay sky news moscow